foreign
[Music]
is ready to launch does he say lunch uh
no I said launch
[Music]
it's giving off some kind of energy
this September I think we've got super
powers
and that's why I wear a hard hat
I needed
for sweet I'm a wrecking ball
look at your paws
now the clumsy pup shoots Fireballs out
of his paws
superpowers are real it's the big screen
how about the PAW Patrol but more
it's a little bit extra
the mighty pops
supposed to be my superpowers
I'm gonna take them one by one
oh my goodness I could talk
I have so much to say give me that
it's so fun well well wow Humdinger he
looks different than I remember
can you go up against one of us
you go up against all of us
now that we're super I'm never gonna get
to sleep well you're probably more tired
than you
oh you've got to be kidding me
[Music]
[Laughter]